[موسيقى]
كشف الصليب الاحمر الدولي عن مفاوضات قال
انه يجريها مع جميع الاطراف في سوريا
للتوصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار وذلك كي
يتمكن من ايصال المساعدات الى المناطق
الاكثر تضررا يتزامن هذا مع اعلان مجلس
قياده الثوره في ريف دمشق بعض المدن
وبلدات المحافظه كمناطق منكوبه وفي ظل
تفاقم الازمه الانسانيه في عدد من انحاء
سوريا بسبب نقص المواد الغذائيه والادويه
وانقطاع
[موسيقى]
الاتصالات حياكم الله نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في عنوانين رئيسيين ما مدى نجاعه
المقترحات المقدمه د ما حتى الان للتعامل
مع الوضع الانساني بالغ التدهور في سوريا
وما المطلوب من الاطراف السوريه والدوليه
المختلفه من اجل انهاء معاناه المدنيين
[موسيقى]
السوريين الحديث عن تردي الاوضاع
الانسانيه في سوريا ليس بالامر الجديد لكن
هذا التردي بلغ فيما يبدو حدا لم يعد
الصمت معه ممكنا
الصليب الاحمر قال انه يفاوض من اجل
ساعتين يوميا يقف فيهما العنف لتصل
المساعدات الى المتضررين بينما كشف الامين
العام للجنه الاغاثه والطوارئ باتحاد
الاطباء العرب عن تقيييم اجراه الاتحاد
لحجم الاغاثه المطلوب في سوريا وعن ان دعم
المدنيين سيكون ضمن اجنده مؤتمر اصدقاء
سوريا في تونس معالجات لم ينتظرها مجلس
قياده الثوره في ريف دمشق الذي لم يجد
امامه بدا من اعلان بعض مدن المحافظه
مناطق
منكوبه 202 2012 لا تملك من الانسانيه غير
اسمها انها اوضاع السوريين المعيشيه اذ
تتفاقم ال الامر علاقه بمطالبتهم بحياه
كريمه في ظل حكم ديمقراطي نترك لكم
الاجابه اما اهالي المناطق التي تصنع ثوره
الحريه منذ ما قبل نحو عامق تركها العالم
لنكبته تبدو سوريا كلها منكوبه بنظام متهم
بممارسه القتل والتجويع والعقاب الجماعي
لكن مناطق بعينها في ريف دمشق اعلنها مجلس
قياده الثوره هناك منكوبه لشده ما
تقاسي لم نعتد ان يصدر تصنيف كهذا من جهات
غير رسميه او امميه لكنها احوال الزبداني
ومضايا رنكوس حكمت بذلك حصار خانق انقطاع
مزمن للكهرباء ووسائل الاتصال كافه شح في
المياه والمواد الغذائيه والطبيه والوقود
وكل الحاجات الاساسيه للحياه اليوميه تصور
الحياه في ظروف كهذه بل ربما هي اسوا في
مدن وقرى سوريه اخرى ثائره على نظام الاسد
احياء في حمصه بالاضافه الى ريفها وكذا
ريف دمشق احياء في حماه مناطق في ادلب
ودرعا ودير الزور وحلب ليس استمرار عمليات
القصف والدهم والاعتقالات والتنكيل وحده
ما يؤرق تلك البقاع فهي جميعا تمر باوضاع
انسانيه اخف اوصافها انها سيئه ويقول
ناشطون معارضون انها تنذر بكارثه انسانيه
حقيقيه بات الماء والكهرباء والخبز وحليب
الاطفال ووقود السيارات والتدفئه عملات
نادره وكذلك هي الرعايه الطبيه حتى ح في
ابسط صورها فالمشاهد امنه لانها تحت سيطره
قوى الامن ثمه امر يشبه المعجزه يبقي
ثائري سوريا صامدين ويعينهم على التكيف مع
واقع يدركون انه بعض من ثمن الحريه التي
ينشدون ربما السر في قوه الاراده ولعلها
روح التضامن التي يقول هؤلاء ان اله القمع
الرسميه وطدت اواصر بينهم من حيث لا تدري
ك الشتاء الذي ازداد قسوه هذا العام في
كافه ارجاء الارض ولم يستثني سوريا لا
يسهل المهمه ولا يسهلها حتما منع الهيئات
الاغاثه والانسانيه الدوليه من بلوغ مناطق
سوريا
المنكوبه لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا عبر
سكايب من ريف دمشق محمد السعيد عضو مجلس
قياده الثوره في ريف دمشق من بيروت معنا
عمر ادلبي عضو المجلس الوطني السوري وينضم
الينا من عمان الدكتور محمد خليل الموسى
استاذ القانون الدولي وحقوق الانسان وابدا
معك محمد السعيد عندما تعلن ثلاث مناطق في
ريف دمشق انها مناطق منكوبه من واقع وجودك
انت في ريف دمشق هل يعكس هذا الواقع الى
اي مدى يعكس
الواقع نعم اختي الكريمه النظام السوري
حاول جاهدا ان يقمع هذه الثوره منذ
بدايتها فارتكب الجريمه الواضحه اولا
باطلاقه الرصاص على المتظاهر العزل ثم
تابع ذلك بقطعه للخدمات كافه عن المدن
وذلك يشمل اختي اول شيء قطع الكهرباء
ويتسبب ذلك في حالات الوفاه بسبب شمول ذلك
المشافي والحاضنات كما حدث ذلك في ادلب
وحالات الاطفال الخدج بحمص وحماه بالاضافه
الى فساد الاغذيه الممونه في الشتاء
وجميعنا يعرف سوريا والمونه التي تخزن من
الصيف وذلك تحت سياسه العقاب الجماعي في
التجويع العام للشعب ايضا الامراض التي
التي رايناها واغلبها لدى الاطفال بسبب
برد القارس وعدم توافر المياه الساخنه
وانعدام وسائل التدفئه الكهربائيه وتعطل
الحياه العامه والاعمال المهنيه والصناعيه
لمدينه الصناعيه في دوما جميعها معطله
بسبب انقطاع الكهرباء لاكثر من 12 ساعه
يوميا قطع الماء وحتى ان القناصه تستهدف
خزانات المياه فوق اصطح الابنيه وحدث ذلك
في عدد من المدن ونقص الماء يتسبب بالكثير
من الامراض حتى الطر الاهالي في رنكوس
والزبداني ومضايا الى توفير مياه الامطار
وايضا لتذويب مياه الثلوج ليشربوا منها
وليستخدم
ايضا قطر اتصالات التي الذي ايضا يتسبب في
حالات كارثيه ب لعدم امكانيه الاتصال
بالاسعاف وحدث ذلك في كثير من المدن حيث
هناك حالات من الحوامل توفوا بسبب عدم
قدوم الاسعاف وهناك ايضا اختي اتلاف
للممتلكات العامه كما حدث في دوما حيث
احترق المشفى الوطني وجاء الاتصا متاخرا
بسبب بسبب عدم القدر على الاتصال به وايضا
هناك حاله توقف الحياه الجامعيه وبالذات
الافتراضيه التي لتعتمد على الانترنت
مصدرا لها اما نشر الحواجز وهي تنشر البحث
عن المطلوبين واعتقالهم بطريقه وحشيه ف
ايضا يصل المريض متاخرا ل المشفى غالبا
ويكون قد فارق الحياه اثناء البحث عن اسمه
على هذه الحواجز ضمن اسماء المطلوبين
يتسبب ذلك بالوفق وحدث ذلك في عربين لضابط
لعقيد متقاعد كان اصيب بنوبه قلبيه وحدث
ذلك ايضا في حمص والدلب والكثير من المدن
وايضا الحواجز هذه ت تتسبب في منع دخول
الاندا الطبيه الى المدن وحالات الاستشهاد
لان الجرحه حالات استشهاد الجرحه لان
الطبيب لا يملك لهم العلاج بسبب منع دخول
الواد الطبيه الى هذه المدينه ايضا اختي
عرقله الحياه الطبيه الطلابيه والجامعيه
بالاضافه لمنعه الجوال واجبار الناس على
اغلاق المحلات التجاريه وعد عن اقتحامها
المحلات ونهبها في سقب بريف دمشق التي
كانت تعرف في مدينه المفروشات هذه
المفروشات اصبحت خط حطبا يشعره الشبيحه
والخسائر بالملايين الاسعار بشكل عام
ارتفعت الى ثلاثه او اربع اضعاف كثير من
الناس باتوا بحاله فقر شديد وخاصه من
يعتمد على الاجر اليومي كالعم الفلاحون
ايضا والمزارعون ثر انتاجهم بشكل كبير وقد
تمت مداهمه المزارع وقتل الكثير منهم
لاتهامهم بايواء عناصر الجيش السوري الحر
الذين ينشقون من الجيش النظامي بالاضافه
لاعتقال بعضهم مثلا في دما بسبب وجود
السماد الزراعي فقط عند الفلاح اعتقل بسبب
وجودها ماده السماد ايضا اخطي صعوبه تنقل
الاطباء وملاحقتهم هناك الكثير من الاطباء
معتقلين مثل الدكتور فايز حلاوي مدير مشفى
الفاتح واطباء مشفى الرجاء بربين الذين لا
يز لا يزالون الان في المعتقل هناك حالات
من الجرحه اصيبت بشلل نتيجه نتيجه نقص
المواد الطبيه اطفال كثيرون عانوا من
حالات الهلع والمشاكل النفسيه والرعب
وهناك معاناه غذائيه اهمها عدم توافر حليب
الاطفال الاعتقالات كانت بالجمله وبوجود
تهمه فقط بسبب الانتماء المنطقه من
المناطق اله ومعظمهم من اصحاب العوا صوره
صوره قاس جدا صعبه جدا رسمتها محمد السعيد
اريد ان اسالك عمر ادلبي يعني هل هذا
يقتصر الوضع بهذا السوء يقتصر على ريف
دمشق ام ان هناك مناطق اخرى تنطبق عليها
مواصفات
نفسها م مساء الخير لك سيدتي ولمشاهده
الكرام للاسف هذا الواقع ينطبق على عديد
على عدد كبير من مدن وبلدات في سوريا
نستطيع الان ان نقول ان معظم مدن بلدات
سوريا هي تعيش حاله ماساويه للغايه وان
كانت تتفاوت في درجات خطوره هذه الحاله ال
الواقع الذي شرحه الاخ محمد من من دمشق هو
واقع صحيح تماما الحاله الاكثر ماساويه
يعني تحصل في ريف دمشق في الزبداني ومضايا
وبلودان
ورنكس ايضا مدينه حمص كما بات معروفا جميع
احيائها دون استثناء باستثناء طبعا
الاحياء
المؤالف تعاني من حاله ماساويه للغايه اخص
بالذكر احياء التي لا تظهر على الاعلام
كثيرا بما ان احياء مثل بابا عمرو وال
الخالديه والبياضه اصبحت معروفه تماما
للناس جميعا هناك احياء كرم الزيتون وحي
الرفاعي وحي عشيره هي من الاحياء التي
تتعرض لحاله ماساويه غايه في الخطوره على
صعيد تامين المواد الغذائيه وايضا المواد
اللازمه للحياه الضروريه
مثل وقود التدفئه وغيرها وايضا في مدينه
حماه كما اسلف تقريركم في ذكر نعم اكثر من
مدينه تعاني اوضاع مشابهه ربما هذا ما دفع
الصليب الاحمر اللي يدلي بتصريح اليوم عن
اجرائه مفاوضات مع كافه
الاطراف كيف نظرتم لهذا التصريح ما هي
الجهات التي يتفاوض
معه يعني هو اعتقد انه تصريح يعني فيه
الكثير من محاوله انتهاج مبدا الحياديه
والدبلوماسيه الى حد ما في الحقيقه هناك
طرف واحد يمنع وصول هذه الموا الغياث يمنع
وصول طواقم الاسعاف الطبي والهلال الاحمر
يستهدف حتى سيارات الهلال الاحمر برصاصه
وسبق وقتل عدد كبير من من مسعفين الهلال
الاحمر في عدد كثير من المناطق السوريه
هذا الطرف الوحيد هو النظام وعصابه عصابات
امنه وجيشه وشبيحته بالنسبه للجيش السوري
الحر الذي يتواجد في عدد من المناطق وقد
يخوض في بعض الاحيان اشتباكات مع قوات
النظام لم يكن في وقت من الاوقات معرقلات
يعني قواف الاغاثه اعتقد ان قافله الاغاثه
التي وصلت الى مدينه حمص منذ حوالي شهرين
تقريبا من مدينه حلب وادلب القوات الامنيه
هي التي اعاقتها وهي التي اعتقلت سائقيها
وهي التي حاولت مصادره المواد الغذائيه
لولا تدخل العقلاء من من قبل بعض الاطراف
سمحت في المحصله بدخول هذه المواد ال
غافيه اذا هذا التصريح الصادر عن اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر الدولي نعتقد انه
محاوله لاقناع النظام السوري بان يسمح
لقوافل الاغاثه بدخول هذه المناطق واخلاء
الجرحى والمصابين وهذه ايضا حاله تحدث في
سوريا فقط لا غير يعني ان تمنع قوات الامن
اخلاء الجرحى والمصابين الى المستشفيات
وعندما يتم اخلاهم ان تعتقلهم من
المستشفيات فهذه حاله فعلا يعني قمه في
حاله الهمجيه والاجرام نعتقد ان التاريخ
لم يشهد لها مثيلا دكتور محمد خليل
الموسى وفق القانون الدولي ما الذي يجب ان
يتوفر ما هي المواصفات التي تجعل منطقه ما
منطقه منكوبه وما الذي يترتب على ذلك
قانونيا هو في الواقع يعني ما اشار اليه
الاخوان الذين استضفت موهم في الواقع
المنطقه المنكوبه هي منطقه تمر بكارثه
انسانيه الكارثه الانسانيه قد يكون سببها
نزاع مسلح او قد يكون سببها طبيعي نحن في
الحاله السوريه هنا امام حاله سببها قمع
ونزاع مسلح نحن امام صراع مسلح هنا في هذه
الحاله هناك كارثه انسانيه الحياه ليست
اعتياديه الناس الذين يقطنون في هذه
المناطق التي تدعى منكوبه لا يستطيعون ان
يتمتعوا بالاساسيات والضرورات المعيشيه
الاساسيه ليس لهم امكانيه الوصول الى مياه
الشرب ليس لهم امكانيه الوصول الى الغذاء
بسهوله ليس لهم امكانيه الوصول الى
المتطلبات الاساسيه للعيش وبالتالي نحن
امام حاله يترك الناس فيها الى مصيرهم في
الواقع و وليس ولا يتمتعون بالحياه
المعتاده من كهرباء من ماء من كافه
الخدمات والمرافق التي يجب ايه ان تتاح
والتي دائ ئما توفرها الدول والسلطات
العامه الى قاطنيها وساكنيها الان ما الذي
يجب عمله هذا سؤال مهم ابتداء هذه المساله
ضرورات المعيشيه هي مسؤوليه الدوله بمعنى
ان الدوله هي التي يجب ان توفر وان تحمي
وتضمن وصول الناس الى هذه المرافق والى
هذه الخدمات في الحاله السوريه المشكله
اننا امام نزاع مسلح هذا النزاع المسلح
يبدو ان السلطات العامه السوريه تركت
الناس الى مصيرهم وتمنع من جهه دخول
الخدمات والسلع والحياه الاعتيا قياديه
وبالتالي لابد في الحقيقه من التفاوض مع
السلطات المعنيه من اجل ان تسمح بوصول
السلع والخدمات وان تسمح ايضا بان تكون
الحياه المعيشيه وفق المتطلبات الاساسيه
التي تكفل الحياه للناس وكرامتهم الان في
الواقع من من التدابير التي دائما نلجا
لها في القانون الدولي مساله استحداث
الممرات الانسانيه بمعنى لابد في الواقع
من الرجوع طبعا مجلس الامن مشلول عاده
مجلس الامن كان كان يعني يسمح بتقديم
المساعده الانسانيه لممرات الانسانيه
لكن انا بالرغم قناعتي ان القانون الدولي
وان شل مجلس الامن ليس هناك ما يمنع في
الواقع ان تتضافر الدول من اجل ان تسعى
جديا الى تحقيق فكره الممرات الانسانيه
الى هذذه المناطق من خلال الصليب الاحمر
او من خلال اليه معينه تمارسها الدول من
اجل ان توصل الخدمات والسلع الاساسيه
لهؤلاء الاشخاص المتروكين الى مصيره هذه
الفكره التي يتبناها بقوه وزير الخارجيه
الفرنسي الان جيبي والتي حتى الان تلقى
صدا كبيرا من جانب النظام السوري على
العموم ما الذي يجب عمله لتخفيف هذه
الماساه وتفادي وقوعها مستقبل الذي طرحته
هذا السؤال الذي طرحته دكتور هو ما
سنناقشه بتفصيل اكبر بعد الفاصل ارجو ان
تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد الى حلقتنا التي
تناقش المقترحات المطروحه للتعامل مع
الازمه الانسانيه مستفحل في سوريا محمد
السعيد اسمح لي ان اقرا عليك ما جاء في
صفحه نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي جنادي
جاتيلوف صفحته على تويتر يقول ان الوضع
الانساني في سوريا يتطلب تقييما موضوعيا
وربما يتوجب على الامين العام للامم
المتحده دراسه ارسال خبراء الى هناك ربما
هذا موضوع ليس جديدا سمعناه من اكثر من
مصدر ولكن عندما ياتي من مصدر روسي
رفيع هل له تاثير
مختلف نعم اختي بالنسبه ل يعني الاعداء
يعني اعداء الشعب السوري شهدوا ان هناك
ازمه انسانيه في سوريا وهم يطالبون الان
بتقدير دقيق ل الحالات الدمار والضرر التي
التي التي تحدث في سوريا وفعلا نحن بحاجه
لهذا الامر حتى نحن كناشطين لا نستطيع ان
ان نوثق جميع الحالات التي يعني جميع
الحالات نوثق عدد قليل من الحالات التي
تصلنا ليس هناك تهويل بالعكس هناك قله في
المعلومات بسبب وجود الحواجز وانقطاع
الانترنت وايضا يعني يعني وملاحقه
الناشطين الذين يقومون بهذا العمل اختي
بالنسبه
لل التدمير البيوت او تدمير الممتلكات
العامه هناك اكثر من 175 بيت مدمر في مضا
تدميرا كاملا الامن يحتل البيوت يعني احت
اكثر من 30 بيت في سقب واحتل من قبل الامن
واكثر من 35 بيت في كسر بطنه واحتل من قب
الامن حتى المساجد لم يتركوها مسجد علي بن
ابي طالب في في
رنكوس تم احتلاله وتحويله الى استراحه
لعناصر الامن و شبيحه مع استباحته بكافه
المحرمات والخمور وكتابه عبارات مسيئه
مسجد الخولاني في حمور ال الان لازال قبوه
معتقلا يعذب فيه المعتقلون وكان من قبل
اسبوع حتى حرم المسجد نفسه معتقلا مسجد
الحمزه في في مسراب كان لمرحله لاكثر من
اسبوعين لم تقم فيه صلاه لا جموعه جماعه
وهو مسجد مهتك و مثقب
وكان في متاريس حتى الجيش السوري يعني
الوضع الانساني
سيضع سيء وبحاجه لتقديرات بح بحاجه لوقف
العنف الذي يقوم به النظام السؤال ك الكل
متفق على ان هناك هناك حاجه لوقف العنف
فعمر ادلب البعض يذهب الى ضروره التدخل
العسكري في حين ان الغرب يصر على انه يرفض
تماما التدخل العسكري حتى ان الجنرال
مارتن دمسي بالامس فقط رئيس هيئه الاركان
الامريكيه المشتركه قال ان واقول لك
بالضبط قال انه خطا ان نعتقد ان سوريا هي
ليبيا اخرى
ولذلك التدخل العسكري غير مطروح الا يشجع
هذا بصوره او باخرى النظام على ان يتمادى
في ما يفعله الان ضوء اخضر ربما هل ترى
ذلك للاسف نعم هذه التطمينات التي تاتي
للنظام من كل حدب وصوب حتى من من قبل
الدول التي يعني تتحدث ليل نهار عن دعمها
لنضال الشعب السوري وعن المجازر التي
يرتكبها النظام هي تتح يعني هي تتحدث بلغه
تطمئن هذا النظام وتتركه يعني مرتاحا
تماما ليكمل عملياته الاجراميه بحق الشعب
السوري عزيزتي ليلى فيما يتعلق ب بالصليب
الاحمر وبما يمكن ان يتخذ من اجراءات في
الحقيقه اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في
نهايه العام الماضي تحدثت في تقرير واضح
لها يعني لا لبسه في عن ان النظام ان قوات
النظام ان جيش النظام يمنع الدخول الى هذه
الاماكن التي يعتقد انها منكوبه وبحاجه
اغاثه احد زملائنا في المجلس الوطني
السوري منذ ايام خاطبا السفير واحد
السفراء الاوروبيين في في دمشق طالبا منه
التدخل لدى الصليب الاحمر الدولي والهلال
الاحمر الدولي لمحاوله اغاثه بعض المناطق
المنكوبه واخص بالذكر حي بابا عمر رد عليه
السفير بايميل رسمي من يعني بايميله
الشخصي الرسمي بان الجيش السوري يمنع دخول
هذه المنظمات الى هذه الاماكن بما معناه
ان ممرات امنه لايصال هذه المساعدات ال
الانسانيه لهذه المناطق المنكوبه بات امرا
بغايه الضروره وفرضه على النظام اما
بالاقناع او بالاجبار ايضا يعني هدف يجب
العمل على تحقيقه من قبل المجلس الوطني
السوري وقل وكل الدول الصديقه للشعب
السوري هذه مساله تتعلق بحياه بشر هنا نحن
لا نتحدث عن مصالح اقتصاديه يمكن التنازل
عنها ويمكن التفاوض حولها هذه مساله تتعلق
ببشر يتعرضون لابشع انواع العنف لابشع
انواع المعاناه من قبل يعني حصار وتجويع
بكل ما تعني الكلمه من معنى هذه المناطق
تتعرض لها اشبه ما يكون بجرائم اباده
جماعيه وان لم يكن الوصف الحقوقي ينطبق
عليها مما يقتضي يعني بالعمل مع الدول
الصديقه
للنظام لاقناع هذا النظام او مع الدول
التي تعتقد انها صديقه للشعب السوري في
نظم ربما
ت
سمعنا يعني عن ان العرض بتقديم 10 ملايين
دولار جاء هذا من الامين العام للجنه
الاغاثه والطوارئ باتحاد الاطباء العرب
ونبيل العربي قال ان هذا سيعرض على اصدقاء
سوريا هذا يعني يبدو انه تحرك جاد في هذا
الاتجاه هل هذا كافي من وجهه نظركم عربيا
فعلا هو تحرك مشكور بالتاكيد ولكن احب ان
اشير الى نقطه في غايه الاهميه هذا الرقم
في الحقيقه لا يكفي لعمليات الاغاثه التي
يحتاجها الشعب السوري الان في مناطقه
المنكوبه العديده والكثيره جدا تقييم
اجرينا في المجلس الوطني السوري منذ فتره
في المكتب الاغاثه منذ حوالي شهرين
تقريبا يعني درسنا بعض الاحتياجات وهي
بالتاكيد ليست كل الاحتياجات التي يحتاجها
الشعب السوري قدرنا التكلفه الشهريه لهذه
عمليات الاغاثه بحوالي 29 مليون دولار
ونحن لم نكن امام حالات قتل يعني كبيره
كالان كنا نتحدث عن 5000 شهيد واسرهم كنا
نتحدث عن عدد بضع الاف من الاسر المهجره
داخليا وبضع الاف من الاسر المهجره خارجيا
الان نحن امام ازدياد كبير لهذه الارقام
نعتقد ان هذا التحرك مشكور وندعم بالتاكيد
نرحب به ونطلب ان يكون تحركا اكبر واوسع
وعلى نطاق يعني يستطيع فعلا اغاثه المبلغ
10 ملايين او 100 مليون
دكتور الموسى في النهايه ما لم يتعاون
النظام وهذا ينطبق على موضوع الممرات
الامنه كما تحدثنا قبل قليل ينطبق على
الطواقم طبيه وما الى ذلك ترى كيف تصبح
مسؤوليه المجتمع الدولي في وجه رفض النظام
القاطع سواء الان او في المستقبل في سبيل
المحاسبه
والتوثيق اولا ابتداء نحن نحن امام مساله
ليست فقط قانونيه مساله اخلاقيه المجتمع
الدولي لا يجوز ان يبقى ساكتا ازاء الوضع
في سوريا انا لا اتحدث عن تدخل عسكري
واستخدام قوه انا اتحدث لي لماذا لماذا لا
نفكر جديا بطرح قرار الى مجلس الامن هذا
القرار ببساطه و وما يدعمه
موقف الروسي الموقف الروسي الذي ذكرتيه في
قبل قليل فقط نطلب ان مجلس الامن يطلب من
السلطات السوريه ان تسمح ل اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر بان تدخل وتقدم ال المساعده
الانسانيه لهؤلاء الاشخاص ال ال المنكوبون
لهؤلاء الاشخاص الذين تتعرض حياتهم الى
الخطر يجب ان نفكر جديا بهذا الموضوع وانا
اعتقد ان ان مقترح قرار في في بهذا
المضمون يصعب يصعب ان يستخدم الفيتو ضده
من قبل روسيا والصين لاننا لا نطالب بتنحي
ولا نطالب بمسائل سياسيه وعسكريه السماح
لهيئه حياديه معروفه
بحيادية واقع هذه الظروف المعيشيه
المفروضه وهي ظروف كما قلت او كما كما قيل
انها من شانها ان ان ان ان ان تشكل ان
تودي الى الى قتل الناس خسرانهم لحياتهم
مساس بكرامتهم هذه الظروف المعيشيه ترقى
ترقى في الحقيقه الى جرائم دوليه وبالتالي
لابد لابد في الواقع من ان نفكر جديا
بمسائل ومحاسبه المسؤولين عنها المشكله
كما قلت اننا امام الفيت الروسي الذي يحول
دون التحرك كما تم التحرك في الحالات
الاخرى ولكن في الواقع هذه الجرائم تب
تبقى قائمه ليس بالضروره امام المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه يمكن يمكن المحاكمه عنها
امام القضاء السوري اذا ما تم تسويه الوضع
لاحقا بسوره او امام محاكم اخرى على اساس
الصلاحيه العالميه هناك اليات المحاسبه
خاصه وانها لا تتقادم ولا تسقط بمرور
الزمن اشكرك دكتور محمد خليل الموسى استاذ
القانون الدولي وحقوق الانسان كنت معنا من
عمان واشكرك عمر ادلبي عضو المجلس الوطني
السوري من بيروت شكرا لك وعبر سكايب من
ريف دمشق محمد السعيد عضو مجلس قياده
الثوره شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لكم مشاهدينا
الكرام على متابعه هذه الحلقه من برنامج
واراء الخبر فيما
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لا